y
confusión y tristeza en el patio de este
instituto de kabul mientras las alumnas
son enviadas a casa antes de tiempo el
miércoles los talibanes ordenaron el
cierre de las escuelas secundarias para
las jóvenes afganas apenas unas horas
después de su reapertura los
diplomáticos occidentales expresaron su
frustración por la repentina marcha
atrás estoy profundamente preocupado por
los múltiples informes de que los
talibanes no permiten que las niñas
mayores de 6 años regresen a la escuela
esto es muy decepcionante y contradice
muchas afirmaciones y declaraciones de
los talibanes todos los jóvenes afganos
merecen ser educados cuando los
fundamentalistas volvieron al poder el
pasado agosto la mayoría de las escuelas
secundarias para niñas cerraron muchos
temían que quedaran totalmente excluidas
de la educación como a finales de la
década de los 90 cuando los talibanes
gobernaron por última vez en el país la
semana pasada sin embargo el ministerio
de educación reavivó las esperanzas de
millones de niñas afganas diciendo que
todas las estudiantes podrían volver a
clase a partir del miércoles
no importa lo difícil que sea la
situación seguiremos comprometidas
seremos más fuertes quiero salir de la
oscuridad con mis estudios y mi
educación estas esperanzas se han
desvanecido ya que los extremistas dicen
ahora que la educación de las niñas en
las escuelas medias y secundarias se
retrasará hasta que se pueda formular un
plan para adaptarla a la ley islámica y
a la cultura y tradiciones afganas las
clases ya estaban obligadas o se
segregadas por sexos y a basarse en un
plan de estudios islámicos incluso las
universidades donde se permite a las
mujeres reanudar sus estudios del mes
pasado la última decisión se produce
justo ocho días antes de una importante
conferencia de donantes de ayuda
internacional los derechos de las
mujeres han sido un punto clave en las
negociaciones de ayuda ya que millones
de afganos están sumidos en la pobreza
en medio del colapso económico tras la
toma del poder de los talibanes